[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Good afternoon.
We're excited to welcome
Gaelynn Lea to Talks at Google.
Gaelynn is a violinist,
a songwriter,
and speaker, who has a
unique take on fiddle music,
incorporating her love of
traditional tunes, songwriting,
poetry, and sonic exploration.
Last year, she won NPR
Music's Tiny Desk Contest,
a competition
drawing submissions
of original songwriters from
musicians across the country.
Since winning the
Tiny Dance Contest,
Gaelynn's musical reach
has expanded significantly.
And she has released an
EP, a full length album,
and has been touring across
the United States and Europe.
In addition to
performing, Gaelynn
speaks about disability,
overcoming challenges,
and the joy of music.
She has a congenital disability
called osteogensis imperfecta,
or more commonly known
as brittle bones disease.
Gaelynn is a strong voice in
the disabilities community.
She uses her music as
a platform to advocate
for people with
disabilities and to promote
positive social change.
Gaelynn believes
society must work harder
to prioritize accessibility
so people with disabilities
can participate fully
in their communities
and use their talents and
gifts without barriers
or discrimination.
For today's talk, Gaelynn
will first perform,
then we'll have a fireside chat
discussion, which will then
lead into a Q&A.
Following the Q&A,
she will close out with
a couple of final songs.
So please be sure to
stay for the whole thing.
And for Googlers in
the audience please
think of your questions for the
Q&A. So without further ado,
please welcome me in joining
to the Chicago Google
stage, Gaelynn Lea.
[APPLAUSE]
GAELYNN LEA: Thank you.
[MUSIC - GAELYNN LEA, "WATCH THE
WORLD UNFOLD"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
SPEAKER 2: Hi, Gaelynn.
GAELYNN LEA: Hi, thanks
so much for having me.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
Absolutely.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: It's a pleasure
to have you at Google.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: It's a
beautiful performance.
GAELYNN LEA: Thank
you very much, thanks.
SPEAKER 2: I love the looping
and the ambience of what
you're doing with the violin.
It's very unique.
GAELYNN LEA: Thank you.
SPEAKER 2: It's very expressive.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: And it's the
beauty of music, the ability
to express yourself,
be creative--
whether it's songwriting,
performing, touring.
How did you get
your start in music?
GAELYNN LEA: Well, I got
started way back in fifth grade.
So the orchestra came
to our elementary school
and played for us to try
to entice us into joining
orchestra the next year.
And I really loved the
sound of the strings.
And I talked to my parents.
And I was, like next year,
I want to join orchestra.
So I didn't really think
about how I was going to play.
I figured-- I mean usually my
whole life has been spent kind
of just figuring stuff out.
So when I got there, I took
the music listening test,
and I was the only student
in the class that year
that got a perfect score.
So the teacher took
it upon herself
to help me figure it out,
even though we didn't really
know how I was going to play.
So I tried a bunch of the
different instruments.
And the cello was too big.
And the violin was too
big on my shoulder,
but we kind of came to
this idea of playing it
up and down like a cello.
And it was really fun, and
I've been doing it ever since,
kind of along this path
that's led down a very
different road than I expected.
But it's always been
the violin first.
So yeah, it's really fun.
SPEAKER 2: Nice.
And who are some
of your influences
musically as a performer?
GAELYNN LEA: Well, probably
the biggest influence
is Alan Sparhawk.
He's in the band Low.
But in 2011, he contacted
me and asked if we'd
like to do a project together.
And I was like, well, of course.
That's cool.
But he introduced me
to the looping pedal
and also to this idea of more
expensive, longer sounds,
and just kind of changed a lot.
And then in other
forms of music,
like I really love
lyrics and harmony and so
like Simon and Garfunkel, and
The Decemberists, and Neutral
Milk Hotel, and Wilco.
I don't know.
Those are the things I
grew up listening to.
But in terms of what
I specifically do,
he was really
influential for me.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: That's great.
Yeah, tell us a
little more about just
working with Alan and the
projects you've done together.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah, well,
we started back in 2011,
as I said.
And it was a live score to a
film, a 1920s Halloween film.
And it was way out of my
range of what I had ever done,
but I don't know.
For some reason, I felt like
this will be a fun challenge.
And he looped my
violin in that project.
And so I would just play
harmony to what I was hearing,
and we kind of--
we practiced a lot.
I think we had like six or
eight pretty long rehearsals
for that.
And so after we were done,
he's like, that was fun.
We should probably
book some shows.
So we booked a show
later in the month.
And a couple of days
before the show, I
happened to write my first song.
And it kind of came
out of nowhere.
And I showed it to him.
And he's like, that's good.
Let's do it tomorrow.
So the-- which was so scary.
SPEAKER 2: No time
like the present.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah, that
wasn't what I was expecting.
And so we did it the next day.
And "The Murder of Crows" kind
of evolved into like about half
of my songs and then
half instrumentals.
And then he would do one or
two of his songs now and then.
And it became this
kind of unique blend.
But it was really
him just like helping
me get a start in
songwriting, which was cool.
I mean, the singing part,
it wasn't part of the plan,
I don't think initially.
SPEAKER 2: It's a
lot of improvisation.
GAELYNN LEA: Oh,
a lot of improv.
SPEAKER 2: Figuring
it out as you go.
GAELYNN LEA: Yep, yep, and
then he brought me a looping
pedal at one of the
band practices and said,
this is for you.
I think you'll like it,
like you should work on it.
And someday you'll
perform by yourself.
And I thought he
was not accurate,
but it turns out after a lot of
practicing, it really is fun.
And even solo shows
have been really fun.
Nothing I envisioned, though.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So as
a solo performer,
how has that change been?
Like preparing for shows
and going out on the road,
for example, what are the things
we might just take for granted
or might not necessarily
realize in that process for you?
GAELYNN LEA: Oh, well, for in
touring in general, you mean?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
GAELYNN LEA: Well,
touring is awesome.
I get to do it with my husband.
And it's really, really
fun to see the country
and meet all these new people.
Some of the things
you don't think about
is just like you have to play
no matter how bad you feel,
or how stressed out you are, or
how tired you are and just like
creating that mental energy.
Or like how weird the
venue is or the sounds--
you just kind of
have to go with it.
And and that's
something that I guess--
I performed a lot before
we left, but on the road,
you're not going to
have all good days.
So you've kind of
just got to find a way
to connect with the
music and the audience
and remember that it's
not all about you.
And so it's actually
all about the audience.
So you have to just be there for
that, because that's your job.
You know what I mean?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
GAELYNN LEA: So it's a
little different take,
but it's still--
I mean, I still get the
same like rewards out of it
than I did when I was
playing back at home,
just on a little bit
different context, I guess.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
So in terms of the music and how
you connect with the audience,
just the tone of your songs,
just the looping, the violin
work, and just a
lot of the subject
matter that you
sing about, what is
that like, just connecting
with the audience, the feedback
you get from folks?
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah, my songs
are kind of intense, I guess.
I think a lot
about spirituality.
And I think with my disability,
I've had some near--
I wouldn't say near death
experiences like that.
But I've had some experiences
that have been kind of scary.
And I think that that
kind of reminds you
at a younger age
than maybe normally
that you're not immortal
and that life is short.
And you have to
make the best of it.
And I know that informs
my lyrics and the subject
matter that I write about.
And so yeah, so I guess
they're kind of intense songs.
And the violin is a very
beautiful instrument
that has all these long tones.
And it clearly--
I think it sounds like
pretty close to a human voice
in a different way.
And so people respond
pretty strongly to it.
And it's cool,
because I get to hear
what it is about the
song that drew them in.
And a lot of times I get to hear
about their lives after shows.
Like I really like
meeting new people
and learning about what
they liked about the music
but then also just what
their lives are like.
Meeting new people
is the part, I guess,
I wasn't thinking as
much about when we left.
And then all of a sudden
it's like the main thing
that touring is.
That's like what you do
is you meet new people,
and it's really cool.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
And seeing you perform
live, it's definitely
different than on
the recordings,
just because I think
of that connection,
that in-person connection
that's going on.
So even coming up, and
it was like, oh, wow.
I'm taken aback by it
because of the intensity.
GAELYNN LEA: Cool.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Speaking
of intensity,
and thinking about
just shifting gears
a little bit, let's
talk a little bit
about the Tiny Desk Contest
and how that has just
changed your experience
as a musician
and like career-wise what the
ramifications of that has been.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah, well,
I was glad they warned me
that things were going to
change when they told me.
I guess I kind of had a
feeling, but I didn't really
realize the implications.
So after the Tiny Desk
Contest was announced
and we went out to DC, we
did a few shows with NPR.
And they were great.
They're such good people.
They're so awesome.
And then I met-- like,
I met Martin Atkins.
He's from Chicago.
And I've just been meeting
people through that.
That was the first big thing.
But then the thing I
wasn't really like--
you know, I didn't
really know how
it would go down is I
got a lot more offers
to play farther away.
And so I started working with
a booking agent last summer,
and he has been
booking us pretty much
nonstop since October.
So we-- my husband and
I-- both left our jobs,
and we sold our house.
And we bought a van.
And we literally
like has been touring
for the last many, many months.
And it's been really fun.
We've been to 37 states and
done, I think, 150 shows
and been to five countries.
And it's just like a
very different life
than I had before.
I was teaching fiddle
lessons in my hometown,
and I was really
enjoying that too.
But this has been really cool,
like a very big adventure
for us and definitely because
of the Tiny Desk for sure.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Wow, wow.
GAELYNN LEA: So a
lot has changed.
SPEAKER 2: Sometimes
people, they'll
be done being on the
road and touring,
and they'll go and do
teaching, for example.
GAELYNN LEA: And I
might do that again.
I loved teaching.
But we're going to
just kind of keep
going until we don't
want to anymore.
But, you know, we did
a seven-month thing
where my husband had a leave of
absence from work to help me,
because I can't tour by myself.
Obviously I needed a
lot more assistance.
And so he's the guy
that helps, and they
were very understanding.
And they said, sure, go see.
And hopefully you'll come back.
But if you don't,
that's good news for us.
And so they let us try it.
And at the end of
the seven months,
we decided to keep going.
SPEAKER 2: Wow.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
It's been fun.
SPEAKER 2: So Europe,
the US, the UK as well.
So you've been on
the road for a while.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Tell us a little
more about your experiences
with touring.
GAELYNN LEA: Well, you
know, touring is one thing.
Like it's really,
really, really fun.
It's pretty intense.
You drive a lot.
You don't always
get enough sleep.
And you are eating
a lot of corn nuts.
[LAUGHTER]
But then touring
with a disability
has been a whole
another different thing.
So a lot of venues
aren't accessible,
I would say more than half.
I mean, it's solidly
more than half.
And they might be
accessible to the patrons
but not to the performers.
And so people are always
lifting my chair up
or are getting ramps
out of the van.
And that's OK, but it's
just another level of work.
And it's not OK.
That's the weird part about it.
It's like I am a
pretty flexible person.
And I've grown up adapting,
but if you think about a venue,
just making it
welcoming and accessible
provides me the same experience
that any other performer would
have.
Like you don't picture Aerosmith
being lifted on stage by four
people and like arranged in
his chair before he plays
or any artist.
Bands don't have to do that.
It's of like-- it changes
the vibe of what's
happening on stage.
And so a lot of venues
will equate to like, well,
if we help you get on
stage with your wheelchair,
if we all lift it, then they
don't need to get a ramp.
But really, being able to
just do things on my own
has a different level of
like dignity and self-control
and just things that
most performers get
to do without thinking
about it, you know?
And then, yeah, just trying
to find accessible hotels
and like just different
little things that I guess
I didn't really realize
how much they added up
until we went on the road with
another musician named Jess
Klein, and she's a
really awesome lady.
And we did 12 shows together.
And she's like, holy cow.
I thought touring was
hard, but you guys
are working really, really hard.
But it doesn't have
to be that way.
And that's kind of the
message I want to spread
is that accessibility
can be a priority.
And there's got to
be creative ways.
Like there's one venue that
just wasn't accessible, not even
to the guests, you know.
Like people couldn't
have gotten in.
And so I said, I'm really
uncomfortable speaking
about disability rights
and then playing at a place
where people with
disabilities can't even go.
So the venue was awesome and
moved the event to a church
and hosted it still, and
they were the sponsor.
But they moved it.
And there's creative solutions
like that all over the place.
And I think we
just need to start
talking about it more, seeing
what we can do as a community.
I understand that
some things are
cost prohibitive in the
moment, but there's always
fundraising or being
creative in different ways.
So some venues build ramps, and
those are my favorite venues.
They like go out of their
way to have it ready when
we get there, and that just--
SPEAKER 2: It's good.
GAELYNN LEA: It just
warms my heart, I guess.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
Just in thinking about venues
in Chicago, for example,
many of them could be
just very difficult
for people who were
able-bodied to access at times.
So it sounds like
from your experience,
you might have a whole new
set of opinions about that.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
And I try to be
understanding and give people
the benefit of the doubt.
But I think changing
the dialogue from,
wouldn't it be nice
if we were accessible?
To, we are really going to
try to become accessible.
That would be cool.
That's what I'd like to see.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So as an artist,
and just the purpose of the art
can be such an important thing
for giving people a voice
and giving people access.
How do you see
yourself as a musician
being able to give people
more of a voice in this area?
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
Well, I clearly can't speak
for everyone with a disability,
and I don't want
to try to portray
more opinions than my own.
But I just think
representation in the media
is a really important
thing and in the arts.
Because if you're thinking
about health care, for example,
and all these like reforms that
people are talking about right
now, and you never see a
person with a disability,
they're not going to
come to mind right away.
You know what I mean?
And I think the arts have
a really important function
to make it one of the first
things you think about,
because you've seen it before.
And I can have a message to
my music or I don't have to.
I don't think it's about
even the words I'm singing.
It's just about being in the
physical space of a performance
venue and people making
that connection that,
oh, this does exist.
You know what I mean?
And people with
disabilities can go out
and do the things that they want
to do and pursue their dreams.
And this is a reality.
And one of my newer songs that's
going to be on the next album
is actually about
disability rights.
But that's the first song
I've ever written specifically
about that issue, because I do
think I don't need to always
be singing about it.
But I do want to
be talking about it
in talks like this and just
kind of raising awareness.
As a public figure you
can do that, and then just
by setting an example
in the public sphere
so people can see it.
You know, we think about
festivals, for example, right.
That's a big one.
I was talking to a
festival organizer,
and I understand
why she said it,
but she said, well,
we don't pick acts
based on their disability.
But of course, if
there's a talented person
with a disability
we would have them.
And I said, yeah, but if you
had an all white male lineup,
you would hear about it.
Like, you definitely would.
Like first sure, people
would be outraged.
And yet, disability doesn't
have to be anywhere on the bill
and nobody says anything
yet, because it's so far
out of the public sphere still.
Like, we're working.
And we're working.
And it's getting
there, where there's
a little more infiltration
where people start to notice.
But hey, there's no
one with a disability
represented, but
we're still pretty
new at this in terms of--
people have been working really
hard to do it for a long time.
But I'm saying like that's not
something that you think about.
She hadn't made that connection.
And when I said
that, she's like, oh.
You are right.
We would hear about that.
And so why people aren't
demanding more people
with disabilities in
the media is probably
just because it hasn't
been around that long.
And the more you
see, the more you'll
notice that it needs to
be there and that it has
an important place, you know?
SPEAKER 2: For sure.
And again, like in the music
industry just in general,
again, you don't really
see that as much.
How do you see that
changing for the better?
And how can your
audience, people
who have been touched by
your music, how can we
actually maybe--
GAELYNN LEA: Contribute to that?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, contribute
and take a different approach.
GAELYNN LEA: Well, I
think one of the things
is I've heard the
misconception that there aren't
as many artists out
there with disabilities,
but I would argue that a lot
of people with disabilities
haven't had a lot of
opportunity to grow their skill.
I started at open mics
like 10 years ago.
I didn't just like walk out
and try the Tiny Desk and win.
You know what I mean?
I'd been playing a lot.
And I was lucky to have
supportive people that
helped me.
But if the venue that the open
mic is that is inaccessible,
how are they going to get there?
And how will they learn their
craft to really pursue it?
or even just learning an
instrument in the first place,
if you're a music
teacher, be creative.
That teacher that I
had in fifth grade
could have easily
looked at me and said,
you should just do choir.
I mean, really, she
could have said that.
And it might not have
even seemed that weird.
And I'm so grateful
that she didn't do that.
But a lot of teachers
have more power
than they realize at helping
shape the future of the arts.
And so that's cool that
she was willing to do that.
And then the other thing
I would just say is like,
if you're planning events
of any kind, make sure
accessibility is not just like
a thing you think about and say,
oh, darn, this one won't
be accessible, but really
be creative and try to make
sure you can, indeed, make it
something people can get to.
And if you don't know the
answer to how to do that,
talk to people
with disabilities.
Because I'd be happy to share,
and a lot of people would.
Because they want to
be included, you know?
And we're not going to say,
well, the only way I'll go
is if this building builds
an elevator, not necessarily.
There are other solutions
besides just saying
we don't have $100,000 to that.
I guess I won't go.
And moving events to better
venues is a part of that,
to be honest, in my opinion.
And that's not something
everybody wants to hear.
But I think thinking
about where your venue is
is kind of an important part in
this whole sphere of the arts.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
So the venue, you
shared an example
of a venue, where they changed
venues and moved to a church.
Have you had other experiences
where maybe that has also
occurred?
Or is it--
GAELYNN LEA: So far
that's the only one,
but that's pretty recent.
Because it kind
of dawned on me--
I mean, I know that's silly,
but I hadn't thought of that
as an option.
And I was racking my brain,
and I was like, well,
I cannot do a show where
someone in a wheelchair shows up
and they can't--
like, I can't do that.
And so it just
kind of struck me.
But I'm going to use
that as a suggestion.
A lot more often
we have done things
where maybe the gig will be
on the main level instead
of the usual upstairs room.
Or if the stage is
a billion feet tall,
sometimes I play in
front of a stage,
partly because it's not
really great for my wheelchair
to be lifted up, and partly
just so people think about it.
Like, oh, she's
not on the stage.
I wonder why.
Oh, there's no ramp.
You know and like point
that out in a subtle way.
And I don't want to talk
about it while I'm playing,
but you know?
I think it's important
to just start
in a nice and respectful way--
because I don't think you get
anywhere by attacking people,
but in a way, just saying,
this is actually
an important issue.
And we can be flexible to some
degree, but at some point,
things do have to
search changing.
And that's just going to take
a little bit of growing pains,
I think, you know?
And that's OK.
There's nothing wrong with that.
It's important.
SPEAKER 2: For sure.
And definitely I
would say at Google,
we really want to make sure
that space are accessible.
It's definitely
an important piece
of what Google cares about.
Diversity inclusion
is hugely important.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So that said, I
had another question for you
around just your
passion for music.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: I think
I read someplace
that at one point when
you were growing up,
you had an opportunity
to have surgery,
and you actually chose
violin over that.
GAELYNN LEA: Mhm.
SPEAKER 2: Can you expand a
little bit more about that?
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah, so
there's a surgery-- well,
a bunch of surgeries.
I would have had to
have four different ones
where they would have broken
the bones in my arms and legs
and put her right in there
and straightened them.
And you have to do one
at a time so that's
four different operations.
And I just am grateful that
my parents let me decide.
And you know, a lot of people
had those surgeries when
they're very young, so
it's not like that's bad.
It's just that my
parents said, well,
we'll just let her choose.
So as I got older, I
kept thinking about it.
And the option was on the
table, and I knew about it.
But then when I
started playing violin,
one of the potential
problems with that surgery
is that you can damage
the nerves in your hands.
Because straightening
your arm that much
is very stressful on the nerves.
And I just didn't want
to not be able to play.
And there was no way I
know, and so I decided
not to have the surgery.
I mean, also what
10-year-old wants
to have massive amounts of
surgery if they don't have to?
But that was, truly,
the deciding factor
was I just didn't want to not
be able to, because I really
enjoyed music.
And that's maybe
the biggest message
is disability
isn't actually bad.
To me, I had a really
awesome childhood.
I had a lot of cool
experiences, and I had
good friends and good family.
And wheelchairs I could tell
were getting better and better.
And the world was
getting more accessible.
And I didn't feel this
need to be completed
by being able to walk.
I didn't feel like that
was necessary to be happy.
And ultimately, music was
necessary to be happy.
And so when I do
a lot of speeches,
I'll talk about disability
pride and the problem
isn't the disability itself.
It's society's inaccessibility.
And when you reframe it that
way, it takes away the pity,
and it also puts
responsibility on society
to make sure that they're doing
a good job of being accessible.
Because I have an
awesome life, and I
wouldn't be who I am without
my disability, for sure.
And so I don't regret
it or dislike it or wish
I was some other way, you know?
SPEAKER 2: That's great.
Yeah.
And how do you see that
maybe changing just
in general in spaces,
even beyond music,
say how society can
do a better job?
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah, I mean, there
is a lot of work being done.
And I think we're getting
there, slowly but surely.
If you picture where we
were 110 years ago, I mean,
people with disabilities lived
in like back rooms of houses
and never went out.
And it's so much
different than that,
but it's because of
a ton of activism.
The Disability Rights Movement,
the ADA, all these things
didn't just happen.
They were huge
amounts of work that
went into demanding
that that change.
And there's still a
lot of work to do.
The fact that we're
talking about cutting
health care, Medicaid.
I mean, people will die and
end up in nursing homes,
and that's a really big deal.
But obviously people
are fighting that.
So there's a lot of work to do.
But I've seen progress.
I mean, any new building in
America has to be accessible.
And I think that's really cool.
I think we need to work better
with small businesses that
are older to get them up-to-date
and not see it as like a,
this doesn't have to happen
because I'm an old building.
You know what I mean?
Work on that.
And then work on job inclusion.
It's much harder to get a
job if you have a disability.
One of the reasons
I'm self-employed
is it was easier than
trying to convince people
that I could be hireable.
And I have a college
degree, you know?
But it was difficult. So there's
a lot of work to be done,
but there's progress for sure.
I mean, I just know
that kids now--
I've met older people
with disabilities who say,
I wish that I was able to have
pride in my disability the way
the younger kids are.
I think the reason it is, is
because the culture is shifting
towards more
acceptance of yourself
and of your body and
pride in who you are.
And that is a real thing,
I think, that's happening.
And I can only speak for
myself, but there is progress.
But definitely there's
still work to do.
And just reaching out and
asking what the work is,
is a really good first step.
SPEAKER 2: So that's
a good first step.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
Having toured internationally,
have you seen any differences
in how other cultures--
or at least in Europe--
might approach people with
disabilities compare to the US?
GAELYNN LEA: You
know, I thought it
was going to be more
different than it was.
They don't have
legislation like the ADA
in a lot of other countries.
But like Prague,
especially, which
was weird because
it's super old,
it was surprisingly
OK where we were.
I'm sure there are
parts that aren't.
But like I could have probably
brought my electric chair.
I didn't bring it,
because I had no idea.
And then certain parts of like
London was pretty accessible.
Amsterdam wasn't as
accessible as I expected.
But, I mean, it was comparable.
New York City is terrible,
so it depends on what you--
you know what I mean?
Every city has got
its own threshold.
And there's activists
in all those cities
trying to make it better.
SPEAKER 2: It's good.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
Well, we have about
five more minutes
before we open up it up to
Q&A. So for any Googlers
in the audience, be thinking
about any of your questions.
So I'd love to hear
a little bit more
maybe about I guess your album
and your recent EP that you--
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
GAELYNN LEA: Well,
my first album
came out in November
of 2015, and I really
wasn't planning on putting
any singing on it at all.
It was going to be
traditional fiddle tunes
and some standards played
with a looping pedal.
And they're really rearranged.
Like you'll recognize
the melodies
if you like fiddle music,
but they're not always played
in the regular order.
And the rhythms are different,
and the textures are different.
But then I did end up
including one original song
in a traditional
song that I sing on.
And then after I
won the Tiny Desk,
people started
asking me where they
could buy the song that won.
And the answer was nowhere,
so I had to record it.
So I recorded that on an EP
with a guitarist friend--
not Alan Sparhawk,
but a guy named
Al Church from Minneapolis.
And he is awesome, and
it was very, very fun.
It was a fun project.
And now I'm working on my
third full length album.
I did a Christmas album
too in November with Al,
and it was really
fun, Al Church.
And then we're
doing a full length,
but this one, not every song
I've written can be looped.
And so this one is going to
be more of a full band sound
because not every
song is loopable
and just because it's fun.
There's a really good drummer
named Marty [? Dosh. ?] And Al
Church is on there and a
guy named Dave [? Mailing ?]
and Andrew Forman and Alan
Sparhawk's going to join me
for a couple of songs too, so
I'm super excited about that
album.
And that should be out.
I'm releasing a couple
of tracks in November.
And then there's a full
length hopefully out in April.
And there's a GoFundMe for it.
So I'm like in the
middle of that right now.
We just recorded four of them.
SPEAKER 2: Great
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
And four of the songs.
It's super fun.
I don't know, recording
was scary at first.
And it still does
kind of intimidate me,
but when you're with
really creative people,
it's just more of like this
glorious creation process.
So it's been really fun.
SPEAKER 2: Gotcha.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
So other marathon
sessions in the studio
going, toying around with
reverb settings and delays
and all that?
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
We had a full weekend.
This was our first time
we got to get together.
And there was two full
days, and then a half day.
And man, it's hard work.
It's fun, though.
I mean, we laughed a lot.
We eat a lot of tacos.
That's our main--
SPEAKER 2: Tacos are good.
GAELYNN LEA: --sustenance.
Yes.
So, it was very fun.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Gotcha.
And here in Chicago, you
actually just came back
from a recording
session, is that right?
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah I recorded
a cover of a Pigface song,
of course, right?
So--
SPEAKER 2: As you do in Chicago.
GAELYNN LEA: As you
do in Chicago, yes.
No, it was fun.
I played at their
25th anniversary show,
and I did a cover
of "Point Blank,"
and we just recorded that.
And that's going to be fun too.
It's been great getting
to know Martin and then
his extended Pigface family.
A lot of them were at my show.
I had a show last night,
and a lot of them came.
So it was really, really fun.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Martin's
a friend of Google.
GAELYNN LEA: Yes.
SPEAKER 2: And he's had a
Google Talk here as well,
which is going to be
up on our channel soon.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Also I
guess it's worth
noting that we have some of
your CDs for sale in the back,
so for Googlers in the audience,
be sure to check that out.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Well,
it's very exciting.
At this point, I think
we can open it up
for Q&A if anyone is interested
in asking Gaelynn questions.
There's a mic up at the front.
So we'll give you a
second to come on up.
GAELYNN LEA: Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
It's really great
to hear you speak.
I actually discovered you
from the Austin 100 for South
by Southwest.
That was actually where--
I'd heard about Tiny Desk but
didn't actually hear your music
until the Austin 100.
When it came on, it was like,
I need to hear more of this.
GAELYNN LEA: Cool!
AUDIENCE: So it's
wonderful to get
to hear you speak in person.
I was curious, as you
were talking about,
you've done I think
over 150 performances,
if there's any particular
performance that stands out
from the past year that
might be your favorite
and why that might be.
And then is there
any venues or places
that are on your bucket list
that you really, really want
to play?
GAELYNN LEA: Oh,
that's a good question.
In terms of favorite
shows, that Pigface 25 show
was pretty amazing.
It was at the House of
Blues, and it was just
like such a great vibe.
And then Paul and I, I
mean, the Europe trip
was pretty spectacular too.
My favorite, maybe, was
this show in Belfast--
no, Kilkenny in Ireland.
And I do a song that's a
sing along with the audience.
And I like ended the song,
and they didn't stop singing.
And so then I was
like, OK, so then I
like sang with them for awhile.
And then I tried
to end it again,
and they still
didn't stop singing.
So Alan had to end the
song, because I was
like, I don't know what to do.
And how long will they go?
I have no idea.
And that was pretty memorable.
And just like, I don't know,
every show is pretty special.
It's like they're all
different, but they really
do-- like I've played
at some schools.
There's a school for
kids with disabilities.
And they also brought
in a Catholic school
at the same time, so I
played for two schools.
And they were just so pumped.
They did the sing along
with me, and they like--
I don't know.
It was just such a happy vibe.
There's a lot of good
shows, but those are some
of the ones that stand out.
And then bucket list venues--
I don't even know.
I mean, I don't know.
Last night at Reggies
was such a great vibe.
I don't know.
Any room where the energy
in the room is positive,
and the people are engaged
and like, I don't know,
it can be any size room.
I don't really have a
venue in mind, I guess.
It'd be fun to play
more festivals.
Those are really cool, and I
haven't done a ton of that.
South By was one of my
first solo festivals,
so that was kind of cool.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
GAELYNN LEA: Thanks.
SPEAKER 2: Thanks.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm so inspired by
your positive outlook
on life and your attitude.
And I was just wondering
if there anything else
you attribute that to.
I mean, it might just
come naturally to you,
but if there was
anything in your life
aside from society kind
of being more appreciative
and understanding of people
with disabilities and kind
of where you draw
that energy from.
GAELYNN LEA: Cool, thanks.
Well, I mean I can't say that
it's not partly inherent.
I'm sure that it is.
And my parents are really
good at drawing out
like the positives.
And so I got that.
But then I also read a lot
of things about spirituality.
You know, Christianity
and Buddhism
have both been really
influential to me
and just the idea of extending
grace to other people
is an important thing.
I mean, I am
definitely not perfect.
I can give you about
a billion examples
of times I've been a jerk.
But I'm just
saying, in general I
strive to be understanding and
compassionate and like loving.
And I think that's because I
do think life is this really
cool opportunity to grow.
And I don't know.
Like, that really motivates
me to try better and just do
better and not
necessarily mastering
skills, even, so much as
being a better person that's
more loving.
And I think we can all
improve on that, obviously.
And so it's like a quest
that will never end.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you so much.
GAELYNN LEA: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
GAELYNN LEA: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming
to Google and sharing with us
your music, your life.
I was wondering if you
can share a bit with us
the type of curriculum
that you have followed when
you started to play the violin.
For example, you hold the
violin in an untraditional way.
Was the studies that you had
to do, had to be adapted?
How did it work?
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
Luckily I was sort of oblivious
of all that at the beginning.
But you know, I play regular
violin music, or I did it.
But some things
had to be adapted.
Luckily my teachers
both at the beginning
had some understanding
of the cello.
So many of the techniques I
use are a little more related
to the cello.
I shift around the
fingerboard more
because I can't use my pinky.
And so I have to move more.
And my bow, I hold it
like a bass player.
And so probably my bow technique
is definitely not the same
as violinists'.
But I did the regular
curriculum in terms
of like I played the same
music that my orchestra played
and the same parts and just
kind of adapted them as we went.
I was very blessed to have
teachers that were like--
I mean, they would
be up front with me.
They're like, I've
never done this before.
Let's see how it goes.
And we would adapt
as we needed to.
And that worked out OK.
So when I taught--
because I taught
for three years--
I didn't teach people
how to play up and down.
I taught them how to
play the regular way.
So I looked up like pictures.
And I'd be like,
hold it like this.
But it works, if
you can communicate.
It's a back and forth.
And so I kind of experienced
the same thing in reverse
when I taught other people.
You just kind of have to
figure it out in the moment,
and luckily I had people
willing to do that with me.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for sharing.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah, thanks.
SPEAKER 2: All right, so we'll
go to the Dory really quick.
We have one write in question--
GAELYNN LEA: Oh yeah.
SPEAKER 2: --which I
think I find interesting.
What are the
difficulties of working
with your spouse on the road?
GAELYNN LEA: Assuming
it's a difficulty.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a blessing
and a difficulty,
but mostly it's a blessing.
We've gotten to see so
many cool things together.
And I can be like, remember
that thing that happened?
And he actually knows
what I'm talking about.
I can't picture
touring without him.
I think that would
be super hard.
However, the
difficulties lies in
like shows are stressful
for us in different ways.
I might be really
nervous before a show
and be like a little snappier
or tense or like a little more
stressed out,
depending on the day
if we didn't get enough
sleep or whatever.
And he's more like-- he's
the merch guy, right?
And so he has to talk to
like a million people right
after this show.
So we joke sometimes that like
it's like he has a show too.
It's just not the same.
So sometimes those
things collide.
And then I'm not
the timeliest person
on the planet of the Earth.
And so he's way more
on time than me.
So he'll be like, we
should be leaving.
We should have
left, like let's go.
And that's good.
I mean, ut actually probably
keeps me more on time.
But yeah, you run into that.
And then we're basically
living in hotel rooms together,
so you don't have a lot
of space to yourself.
But I don't think that's
a super big problem.
We've gotten used to that.
Yeah.
I mean I realized there was one
night where I went away with
a friend, and it was the
first 24-hour period--
not even-- I mean I'm
talking like four-hour period
that we hadn't been
together since October.
And this was in May.
And I was like, oh my gosh, we
have been gathering nonstop.
So even though we can
like bicker or whatever,
we never hold on to it.
And it's been fun to see
that you can actually
adapt to living like
extremely close quarters
with another person.
So that's cool, actually.
I mean, we might joke
about it sometimes,
but overall it's
been really fun.
So yeah.
SPEAKER 2: That's great.
GAELYNN LEA: But yeah,
you are connected.
I mean, this is his business
as much as it is mine now.
Like, he quit his job.
And that's kind of a big deal.
So like we are both
invested in it,
and that is probably helpful
to keep it like a team effort.
Because it really is at this
point, totally a team effort.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: That's amazing.
GAELYNN LEA: Cool, yeah.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 2: Life on the road.
GAELYNN LEA: I know.
I know.
I never would have thought.
Oh, a couple more questions.
SPEAKER 2: Maybe a
few more questions?
GAELYNN LEA: One more question?
SPEAKER 2: Great.
AUDIENCE: Hi, one more question.
As you were
speaking, how did you
find accessibility to be
for this office at Google?
GAELYNN LEA: I thought
it was awesome, yeah.
You guys are good.
I think it's really neat when--
I mean, yeah, when the
new spaces come out,
it's like everything gets
more accessible, not less.
So that's pretty cool.
Yeah, I've noticed
positive stuff here.
SPEAKER 2: Good stuff.
GAELYNN LEA: Good job.
SPEAKER 2: Yep.
GAELYNN LEA: You
even had a ramp.
That's kind of awesome.
SPEAKER 2: Indeed.
GAELYNN LEA: Good job.
SPEAKER 2: We'll let our
head of facilities know.
GAELYNN LEA: That would
have if you hadn't, I
suppose-- talking
about it, and then
been like, like when
you had to lift me up.
But you didn't, so thank you.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: All right, well,
thank you so much, Gaelynn.
It's been fantastic
having you here.
GAELYNN LEA: Thank you.
SPEAKER 2: We're
going to transition.
And I'm going to get off the
stage so we can hear Gaelynn
perform a few more songs.
We do have a few
more minutes left,
so if you have time
for maybe two more?
GAELYNN LEA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Great.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
And so a couple things, just
be aware of Gaelynn's website,
which is violinscratches.com.
Her music is
available, of course,
there as well is the
Google Play Store, had
to give a plug for Google Play.
GAELYNN LEA: Good point.
SPEAKER 2: Thanks again.
And whenever she's done,
just please give a warm round
of applause for Gaelynn Lea.
Thank you.
GAELYNN LEA: Thank you.
All All right.
GAELYNN LEA: Thanks.
SPEAKER 2: Thanks so much.
GAELYNN LEA: Oh, can you
turn down the reverb?
Thanks, Paul.
Sweet.
[MUSIC - GAELYNN LEA, "SOMEDAY
WE'LL LINGER IN THE SUN"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thanks.
So this next song is from
my new album, which there's
a GoFundMe at
gofundme/gaelynnlea,
and it's called
"Bound by a Thread."
It's one of the newest
songs I have written.
Thanks for having me, you guys.
[MUSIC - GAELYNN LEA, "BOUND BY
A THREAD"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thanks.